so that division is faster because what
does is it takes this process and do
your notice right every single time that
we've done it lots of things are in
common okay for instance I have a look
at the powers have a look at the powers
of X you get the X cubes and then the x
squared and then you get the same X
cubed and x squared and then you climb
down one power right you get the x
squared and the X and then you get the
same x squared and X and then you climb
down again and you get the X and the
constant the X and the constant it's
very repetitive okay
and so being that I'm expecting it to
just every time I climb down alone the X
power is just going down one if I know
that that patterns in my head every
single time I do this question okay I
didn't need to write that anymore like
you're going to get very very sick of
doing this and it's not adding any more
information okay so the first thing is
synthetic division it saves time by
eliminating out all of the X's okay
it eliminates out all the X's the
important thing I don't want to say X
terms the X purview rules is what I'm
taking out all the doing is I'm trying
is more efficient but most important
thing are the numbers the coefficients
right that's what you're adding and
subtracting that's what really is
important in this situation so that's
what the focus is on it focuses on the
coefficients now there's one other
advantage that synthetic division has
which is not only do not have to write
all the X's which immediately makes this
process like twice as fast but it also
do you remember I keep on coming up
against I keep hitting double negatives
do you notice that it's like I'm taking
away a negative take you a negative not
only is that slower having to wear a
double negative is a plus it's also very
error-prone one of the most common
errors to make is forgetting to
translate a double negative into a
positive
okay so instead of subtraction
actually is what takes you which makes
you climb down this ladder okay instead
of using subtraction it uses addition
everyone's good guy and you don't ever
have to work about work out a double
negative because you're never going to
be subtracting something you're just
going to be adding if it's negative
that's okay you add a negative number
okay so to demonstrate it I'm going to
have a go at this problem here and I'm
going to show you how to rewrite it in
synthetic form okay the place where I'm
going to pick up is this point here okay
that's the point I'm going to pick up
from now a long division you always stop
around the division sign to indicate
that we're doing something different
you're going to write the division sign
but you're going to write it upside down
okay so right for me and upside down
draw for me and upside down division
sign okay secondly what we're going to
do is we're going to write again the
focus is on the coefficients the
coefficients okay
so I'm going to take all the
coefficients in the dividend right which
I'll read them out with me three and
then one careful negative one is a minus
sign which kind of matters right if
there was a plus suppose it'd be gonna
be a totally different hats off minus 1
0 and 11 1 2 3 4 numbers I'm just gonna
write those numbers down okay the
numbers are what matter so I'm gonna go
3 negative 1 0 11 okay you're right with
that so see how the focus is on the
coefficients you kind of assume the last
one will be the constant this will be
the X this will be the x squared that
makes the last one and X cubed okay so
there are the coefficient secondly
because I'm going to make an addition
instead of subtraction I have to flip
something around okay the thing that I
flip is the divisor see how I write x
plus 2 at the front here okay what I
want is the opposite of that number
there I can't - 2 is the opposite of
those no bus on the right
I'm almost ready to begin the last thing
I'm going to do is I'm going to write a
line and extra line there and I'm good
to go now my synthetic division is going
to start first thing I do is I just take
that number at the front this is the
leading coefficient of my dividend right
and all I do is I'm just reminding now
so I have to do there's no change
do you notice every time we were
dividing through by this right you
always just write down it always ends up
being that three that comes up here okay
this was different because of what but
that's because this wasn't bloody okay I
write that down and now my repetition
step begins like you know how we keep
repeating the same step over and over
again I'm gonna do it here so three I'm
gonna multiply 3 times negative 2 is
negative 6 just gonna write it along on
the next one
okay we dealt with this number he just
went straight down okay and then I'm
gonna say well I multiplied it now I'm
gonna add minus 1 plus minus 6 minus 7
right and then I do the process again I
multiply minus 7 times minus 2 is 14 and
then I add what 0 plus 14 it's 14 right
and then I multiply and add one more
time so I multiply I multiply which
gives me minus 28 and then I had which
gives me minus 17 I'm finished that was
it that was the whole Cynthia me
admittedly you didn't have to say wait
hold on what whatever what does that
mean again okay do you remember right
what we were coming with you what we
were doing was we were dividing a
polynomial of what degree what degree is
it what's the minimum degree three very
good degree three and we were dividing
it by degree one right now when you I
putted this out now almost first lesson
right when you do 3 3 divided by doing
one you should get degree two like your
index laws mean to be
three take away one gives you two okay
so therefore your answer will be degree
- okay and so if it's degree 2 the first
the leading term will be an x squared
term so I just take all these numbers
and I pop them in on up this will be a
3x squared this is going to be an X this
will be a constant now what's that last
number again does that look familiar
okay boy was that faster okay
and I admittedly that took a bit longer
cause I have to explain what I was doing
let me show you how quickly this worked
and this time I won't explain it now you
see how worked we're just going to do it
okay um let's do a cubic let's let's
make one up some longer maybe 2x cubed
plus 3x squared minus X okay we'll do
that
and we will divide by let's go maybe X
that's too easy okay no yes
you've got the dividend then you have
the divisor okay all right so um I will
explain a little more as soon as I've
done this as I've done this example the
short answer is if you have those kinds
of if you've got those kinds of divisors
then you might as well go back to long
division
however I'll explain a little bit more
about why that doesn't concern me even
though this is most useful for this
particular case this particular case
that's the most important case so that's
why this is so valuable
okay all right really good all it's your
hat because I promise it's going to go
fast first thing I do my sign and then I
plot my coefficients 2 3 negative 1
negative 4 ok I pull out the opposite of
this number here this is minus 3 so my
opposite is true
done I draw my line and get ready your
brick and mr. okay first thing I just
write that number down to and then I
press adjust multiply add multiply add
walls by advocating multiply add
multiply and change three times this is
what I get to make ever done that's what
few times 36 is 78 multiply and add I'm
finished I hardly have written the first
line by the time I finished this
division okay admittedly I've got a
white with my actual answer is I divide
the cubic degree 3 degree 1 so I'm going
to get a quadratic degree 2 so this is
2x squared plus 9x takeaway so plus 26
remainder 74 and then you get to go